they're still alive
holy [__]
[__]
every Saga has a middle age this is what
happens with James Holland Bob get old
I'm Kevin Smith cheers
[Applause]
folks we are at the movies pop-up uh at
San Diego Comic-Con 2023 right here in
Tin Roof uh in the restaurant uh which
has become we flipped into a fake movies
for the occasion put your hands together
so the folks at home know you were real
[Applause]
welcome to
welcome to call it me can't this year
my Lord things look different every year
I've been here for the last you know
we've been coming since 95. generally I
stay at the Marriott that's right by the
water and stuff and when you use the
bathroom there's the window looks right
out to the marina and the marinas where
like the IMD boat used to be where I'd
interview with people in Sri Lanka and
every year is it they're doing the IMD
boat without me
okay
I am deep [__]
um
so in any event they've got the you know
the marina whenever you look out the
window there's always like a [__]
huge line of people that stretches all
the way down the wharf all the way like
to in the distance you can't [__] see
today uh this morning when I looked out
the window there was no line whatsoever
yeah and I guess that's generally the
hall h line
um yeah and and it's just not it's not
yeah tents are set up usually people
have chairs and the whole works usually
I look out and take a [__] and see a
bunch of people dressed like me yeah
nice right this morning nothing
whatsoever there were joggers and I was
like what the [__] this can't be
Comic-Con
um and that's because uh the SAG strike
uh kicked in last week the good folks uh
at sag decided that it's time for the
membership to strike we are sag members
uh as well so
thank you
so that why are we here [__] it yes
let's [__] go I got a lot of that on
online people were like how are you
doing a show when sag is striking you're
not supposed to go to Comic-Con and it's
that's not exactly true uh if we were
here promoting you know Paramount
Pictures presents [__] Jay and Silent
Bob get old then we couldn't yeah since
we were here representing each other
like we can do whatever the [__] we want
I strike you Kevin [__] you yeah it'd be
so weird if you struck me and just
[__] walks behind me with a sign and
[__]
down with Bob I want more hugs
talk [__]
um I have uh I'm a member of the
writer's Guild and a member of sag so uh
the writer's Guild strike has been going
on for nearly 80 days at this point so I
have gone and struck like I'm off the
picket line in front of uh where did I
go Warner Brothers and Universal with
Mark Bernardin but this is our chance to
[__] strike together I mean you
always could have come with me to show
support for writers but yeah [__]
didn't feel the need to do that but
we can go this week
strike together and when you strike they
give you a blank sign you can write
anything you want
all right what would you write on your
side
um I would write I'm with stupid
I'm with sexy oh [__] wow thank you
for that yeah
I don't know what I would write honestly
I um you would have to be true to brand
and write something vulgar or probably
knowing you you would draw like a [__]
and ball oh [__] yeah [__] and balls
would it spurt and come right on a union
card
I don't think you understand the strike
then there you have it
I
mine will still be a union card
have you been following the strikes I
have not I actually I have you know why
we're angry
um
women's rights no I'm just kidding uh
yes because of residuals there you go
um and because of uh like now they can
for extras and stuff taken CGI and
they're like hey repaid you for the day
but we're gonna use your face multiple
times and such
right that's not it no no oh boo to that
[__] yeah boo those [__] I'm
sick again CGI didn't [__] man I can see
you being an accidental Union Buster
you're like Boo to that [__] you
um so it has been a weird Comic-Con so
far man like it's it it's really nice
because it's roomy as [__] uh you can
move around a lot easier
um there's also I haven't been to the
floor though how's the floor
oh so I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about
I really this has been Comic-Con to me
this is the second year in a row that
we've taken over the Tin Roof Inn and
flipped into a movies
um we get to do our shows here uh we've
got merchandise here we've got food here
there's no [__] reason to live if
they drop the bomb we could [__] stay
right here and stuff
um so I I [__] with the con and as
much as I went over and did a Masters of
the Universe panel
um which was which was fun we announced
a few uh cool things about the show
including uh hordak is going to be on
the show this season and this season is
called Masters of the Universe
Revolution the first one was a
revelation hordak is being played by
Keith David oh yes all right so the
president on Rick and Morty is our
hordak
um so I did that and then I went and did
a panel for chasing Chasing Amy over at
uh the Hilton Bayfront which was
absolutely wonderful but I haven't gone
anywhere near the floor and I don't know
if I will you just asked me upstairs
yeah if you were gonna if like are you
gonna go I wanna yeah I was thinking I
might go tomorrow every year even if
like last year too
even though it's gotten super crazy
um walking like you gotta walk and like
maneuver around people and stuff
um people are grabbing my butt and
things
um but I still like to go I feel like
just to get that feeling
it's like it sounds goofy but we've been
coming like he says it's 95 so we've
literally seen it Grow from like you
know the floor was this was how many
people were on the floor in 95. not
really there was a lot more but it still
was like a normal sized convention and
then all of a sudden the year after got
a little bigger and a little bigger and
then now all of a sudden it's like it's
you can't walk but again each year
there's so many cool
like go into the um the the sideshow and
the the different uh there's a couple
boots that make these statues of like
apocalypse this [__] big and all
every year there's something cool and I
love going to the Hasbro booth and they
always make these dioramas where like
Hoth will be underneath they'll be like
the [__] like they almost make like
an ant farm but for like toys it's
amazing
so I always like going checking that ass
up so I think I'll go to the floor for
at least an hour and [__] and top it out
and just walk through and [__] excuse me
excuse me excuse me and then I might
sound so tough excuse me excuse me so
we'll see you you like going looking for
like the new releases and [__] meanwhile
here we've got some new releases of our
own show them your shirt you're wearing
Jay's wearing a Garbage Pail Kids shirt
uh the good Folks at tops did a set of
Garbage Pail Kids uh uh cards that have
all viewers Universe characters on them
and stuff so what is yours called Jay
well his just says Jay but sure it does
the other one is J I believe
um and yours is silent I mean it's the
same but the pictures I love yours how
it has a lock in the mouthpiece right
it's like you're uh lock on it but I'm
I'm excited dude to be like growing up
and having like you know what's a card
that you remember I was trying to think
of one of the old school ones uh growing
up like collecting and it was like the
worst cards no no but the Garbage Pail
Kids cards that were named I remember
there was like throw up Sally or Susie's
throw up or you know I mean like I was
trying to think of one of the names I
couldn't think of any what is it
oh
there you have it I'll take it
he was so [__] happy when he met the
tops people today he was almost in tears
going like we have our Footprints at the
groman's Chinese Theater but this means
more to me
so now we have this next I want I was
telling them and they were laughing but
I want [__] Jay and Bob as wax
figures and Madam skippity Bop box yeah
that's my next goal in life
um they did something there's also where
you got one of those pop taters back
there oh yeah the pop take Kevin the
song pop Tater pop pop skip
no no they're like the uh Potato Heads
yeah they made a Mr Potato Head of
Silent Bob and now you're fired you're
[__] fired [__]
I'm just kidding they made a piece they
got a line of uh pop taters they're
called and it's like a bunch of people
from pop culture as Mr Potato Heads and
so they did a Silent Bob Mr Potato Head
they sell them they're at the con
they're on I think they're on the floor
on the con but Jay saw this morning
because I had to sign a bunch of them
and he was just like where's the Jay uh
Mr Potato Head and I was like oh they
only made Silent Bob and he was so
profoundly upset where he's like but
we're always together and I was like
well
apparently they thought I was more
famous than you so but here's the good
[__] News man um apparently the Simon
Bob pop Tater has been moving very well
and so Stuart who does all of our
licensing and make sure that we're
knee-deep in toys and tchotchkes and
[__] uh told me to tell to reveal to you
on this show
that they're doing a j pop taterness
yes
because you [__] cried
I'm leaving they're bending to your way
they're cool though and I'm excited
again it's it's like when they made uh
and I I shouldn't be greedy because
honestly for me I'm excited like I
remember they made a Funko of course
they made Jam Bob Funko pops and then
they made a Kevin Smith pop and I was
like what about a Jason music and I was
like the [__] nerve now they have a
potato heads Kevin and nobody I'm always
breaking off yeah I'm like Paul Simon
leaving [__] Art Garfunkel behind I
know I know they call you up and they're
like bro we have this great idea Jay and
Bob [__] Potato Head you're like why
don't you just do Kevin Smith that'll
work better so like but we think we
should add your little buddy and you're
like no [__] him again never never mind
I'm just kidding the [__] rocket
sauce that has allowed me to go as far
as I've gone you're my secret [__]
weapon so whenever they're always trying
to be like oh we want to do a thing with
you I was like please bring the other
guy in like because otherwise he'll
borrow
speaking of whining and and uh having
Tantrums last time we were here
um for Comic-Con 2022 we're here to
we're promoting clerks three which was
about to come out and stuff like that
um you did not
have a second child now you sit in front
of all these people as the father of an
of a fairly newborn son I do a thing
yeah
thank you yeah so he's I can't believe
he's [__] five months already uh we
have a little baby boy now Lucian so now
we have Logan who's eight
um and then Lucian who is five months
old and uh it's it's been awesome but it
it's such a change I feel like just as
we started to adjust to like all right
she's going to school now I have like
three hours to do this this or this
um now it's like now I gotta drop her
off at school run home so I can help the
wife out with the with the five month
old but again it's beautiful he laughs
and he's great
um but man and then like at one point
for one second she's like he's so
adorable I I think we I might want to
have another one I was like oh [__] no
dude this old man I don't think can take
it I might lie to her later when she's
feeling a little better and be like we
should try to have more kids
but really like pull out and ship
because when we were trying to have the
kid it was like all right I'm [__]
you know I'm on a schedule yeah [__]
schedule yeah so even when she didn't
want to or what have you it was just
like make a deposit I was like okay
yeah maybe don't say when she didn't
want to well she never wants to put that
to him
no but it it honestly it's been
beautiful and and I I'm excited to bring
we brought Logan here after a couple
years I actually just you know I love on
my phone like all of a sudden it'll be
like you were here 10 years ago and
it'll show memories
um and it has it wasn't 10 years ago it
was like seven six years ago we brought
Logan and it's like Logan walking around
with me we were at the Starbucks and
they had the Joker painted on the wall
and it's behind her and anyway
um I'm looking forward to like when he
gets a little bit bigger and [__] and I
could start pushing like some [__]
Batman toys on them and stuff and I'll
be play with this son snooze
old man who's like can I have the new
toy and [__]
yeah like I need that Hasbro exclusive
for my daddy or he'll beat me
I want to start having them practice and
[__] I'm like all right I'm the [__]
Hasbro retailer come up to me and he'll
come up like my dad he's gonna spank me
he [__] bangs his head you know like
in movies when someone like bangs their
head on the wall so I believe they're
like he hit me up my kid [__] bang
his head on the wall now
what is it like being that parent to a
boy
um you know all I think about is I
really hope when he gets older his penis
is big like I do I look at it a lot my
wife thinks it's weird because I'm
always like moving it and [__] making
sure like his circumcision well because
you gotta clean it you gotta make sure
like his circumcision is [__] staying
off and it doesn't start to heal around
his helmet and [__] and I'll pull it
back a little bit and I'll be like this
[__] it's a little meaty already like
he's gonna [__] have a tank on him
and she'll be like she's like why do you
care and I was like you don't understand
when you're like 14. when I was 14 we
had to take showers at school right and
if you didn't you got [__] uh bad
grade and and well you would get marks
and then if you didn't take showers
every day at gym class you would it
would add up to get you like a c or a D
in class so we used to have to take
showers all the time and I just remember
like people like looking around I think
oh [__] my shit's a lot smaller than
this guys you know and I'd always be
concerned with that and maybe that isn't
the world we live in now but I I hope
he's okay
I hope he has a hammer time
I think he'll be dealing with issues
like my father used to clean my penis
when I was a child and pull it back so
the helmet didn't grow over yeah
hopefully he doesn't feel like my my
wife always says like my nervous energy
sometimes my Logan will start to act up
and stuff and she's like I think she
feels your nervous energy even though
you're I'm not saying anything she feels
it and hopefully he doesn't feel that
I'm thinking like oh I hope he has a
hammer on him because then he's going to
be all like insecure and be like I hope
like my dad said my dick's big and [__]
I'm gonna catch him at like seven in the
mirror like all right
speaking of [__] Underpants
I keep forgetting I have these on so
show them show them your ensemble
he's wearing Jay and Silent Bob
underwear on the outside
in honor of Comic-Con he's wearing his
um I uh what was that
somebody say take them off
I was like he's got pants on underneath
don't worry we're starting that soon
um I uh um have been um like just
yesterday I guess they announced that uh
Masters of the Universe uh they were
going to make a movie at Netflix and
then I guess the variety did an article
about how the movie was going to cost
200 million dollars so Netflix is like
we're not making the movie anymore and
somehow the calculus of that online for
a section of the audience that did not
like the cartoon that I made a few years
ago was that you [__] killed the
movie
so I've been dealing with [__] tweets
all day long with people who've been
saying the most heinous [__] [__]
which I'll share with you right now
sorry so so while you're looking for
that you're saying that they thought
about making a live action here didn't
they do one with Dolph Lundgren years
ago right off longer than years ago but
they were developing one it was
beautiful
um first at another studio and then they
were doing a Netflix for the last few
years but then it went South I guess
according to the Variety article is
because the budget was like very high
but to other people it's because you
[__] it up yes
exactly that so this is a [__] dude
wrote
um bounding into Comics the website said
uh Kevin Smith rejects the premise that
Masters the universe Revelation
performing poorly had anything to do
with live-action He-Man getting axed at
Netflix first off it didn't perform
poorly we're making a sequel series like
I just said what's that
yeah
not you him yeah I was like what the
[__] I'm taking enough [__] online
but I mean like we did if we perform
poorly we wouldn't have a second yeah so
we're doing a second season and [__] so
some guy responded and he said uh of
meaning I rejected he says of course he
does like every left [__] he doesn't
admit failure or blame others for it
Kevin Smith is a sellout and a loser and
so I wrote uh
I didn't write that
I try to be a little more uh [__]
clever than that I wrote um I have
indeed sold out my Show's at Movies yeah
[Applause]
it's crazy though man some cats get
really upset about that He-man cartoon
and stuff and one cat was insisting to
me he's like he wrote this tweet where
he's like um well why why would they let
you make the [__] movie he completely
didn't even read the story and he
thought they canceled some movie I was
working on but I was like I reading is
fundamental [__] like I
my cartoon is happening we just
announced [__] Keith David and [__]
like that it's the movie that's not
going forward
um so it's been a day of of doing that
it's a delicate balancing act man
between like doing the con and then also
addressing some [__] online [__] but
then at the panel we just did
like uh
um the deadline was there and so like in
the panel I opened with talking about
how the Masters Universe panel is
supposed to have a bunch of casts there
because the SAG strike uh the cast of
course no actors are coming to Comic-Con
this year and stuff
um some actors are like you but not as
an actor you're here as a [__]
podcast yeah yeah yeah so I you know
while I was up on stage I was like and
of course we uh support the actors in
their strike as they battle their
corporate overlords Netflix and uh
Netflix made Masters of the Universe
so deadline [__] retweeted that
um like like me saying it because they
shot video and stuff like that and
instantly I got a call from my agent
going shut the [__] up
I gotta learn to stop [__] talking
man do you think they do you think that
they've realized you were doing it as a
sort of a joke in a sense right because
you were there you would hope but like
how some cats are yeah can't put two and
two together and [__] or they do put two
together come up with five it's it's
been a bit unnerving
um well hopefully you can if they're
like you're [__] out of here bro you
can be like look my little buddy can do
it no man hand it over to you hand me
the [__] balls out he couldn't do
anything I'm like I love the [__]
corporate Netflix
[Laughter]
oh I have the [__] power
just want to show them that clip and
they'll be like we'll stick with Silent
Bob thank you very much
um it is uh Comic-Con happened at a
weird time for me this year I uh just
moved after we've been living in a house
uh for 22 [__] years as house I
bought from Ben Affleck and and uh you
know even though he lived in it for six
months and I lived in for 22 years we
still call it Ben Affleck's house
the power of celebrities so uh we moved
uh to Studio City a couple miles away
not all that far and stuff and uh it's
the first time me and uh Jen are living
by ourselves like when when I first
hooked up with my wife
he lived with us and then we had a kid
and she had to live with us according to
the state
uh and Jen's parents moved in and lived
with us and [__] like Brian Johnson's
lived with us we've had a bunch of
people always living with us this is the
first time where it's just her and I so
the house we used to live in like our
kid moved out got our own house and
Jen's parents who used to live with us
they got their own place so it was just
the two of us in this [__] big house
and it felt stupid so we were like let's
find a new place to live and we did and
so we've been moving into it and that
this suddenly like I was unpacking my
office when I had to like take the ride
down here and stuff but I'm terrified
that like now that it's just her and I
alone in the house and there's no one
else to distract us we may discover that
we don't [__] like each other
especially after the move man because
she's a real book fiend and like I don't
want to say a bibliophile because a
bibliophile is somebody that like reads
books she collects books so she has a
[__] slew of books some of which
she's never opened and [__] and so you
know in in moving I had to leave a lot
of [__] behind or sent [__] back to New
Jersey I own a movie theater in New
Jersey
and so a lot of the big artwork has gone
up at spawn castle and stuff so I had to
part with a bunch of things that went
someplace else so I was like maybe you
should leave some of these books behind
she was like go [__] yourself so she has
been unpacking all these books and books
that like some of which have never been
like cracked open and [__] like that and
she told me today she was like you know
I was like what are you doing and she
was like I'm playing with my books and I
was like you don't really play with
[__] books and [__] and she got all
serious and she was like if I ever like
suddenly die she's going I want you to
make sure you donate all these books to
like some children's charity I was like
if you suddenly die number one I'm going
to be a suspect
so I'll be dealing with that for a long
time but number two like I'm not
donating this [__] books to anybody
like I'm gonna open my own [__]
Library man because she has like
literally like 20 000 [__] books I
saw them I went to Kevin's house to drop
something off when the the guy everyone
was packing up they had some people
helping packing up and when I came up to
the second stairway it was just books
all over and they were piled up right so
I guess they were like organizing like
these will fit together in one box and
and there's hundreds I couldn't barely
walk through it to like drop the thing
off it's like I'm married to Barnes and
Noble yeah
[__] Madness but um it's been weird
because in packing up like I didn't pack
necessarily everything other people
packed a lot of my [__] for me but I've
been unpacking at the new place so I've
been finding like all manner of like
hidden treasures and [__] that I hadn't
seen like a long time like
um years and years ago we got this
blanket that used to be in my house
where I grew up 21 Jackson Street yeah
and my mom always called it the Afghan I
don't know if anybody else is calls a
blanket an Afghan but she was like uh
this is the Afghan it always sat on the
back of the couch like when I used to
watch Roseanne they always had like a
blanket on the couch and I was like holy
[__] other people do that as well
so this [__] Afghan has been in my
life since like before I was born my
father slept under it if he was laying
on the couch watching TV he'd be under
the Afghan my mom like we would [__]
watch she made me watch Dynasty in
Dallas when I was a kid and she would
always fall asleep while she was
watching them and I'd be like Mom she
was like I'm up I'm up what happened
who'd he shoot and [__] like that so she
would sleep under the [__] Afghan my
brother and sister who like slept on the
Afghan many a night when I was a kid I
slept under the Afghan so at one point
when my mom moved she was like I'm gonna
give you the Afghan and I was like
[__] a and I brought into the house
and my wife was like that ugly blanket
is never going on anything we own and so
it went up into a [__] closet for 20
years so while I was cleaning out the
place I found the [__] Afghan and I
was like oh my God it was like finding
lost treasure and [__] so we moved to
the new house and once they moved in the
couches the first thing I did was put
the Afghan on the couch and she came in
and looked at it and she was about to
say something I was like hey Bookie shut
the [__] up
and so now the Afghan lives on the
[__] couch man nice nice
it took 20 years but I found my balls
ladies and gentlemen
um the uh but you moved not too long how
many years ago did you move uh I mean it
feels like it's only been a couple
months but I feel like it's been well
it's been since little man's been here
so it's been seven months eight months
ago we maybe even nine months we moved
um and it's tough because for me and I
don't even have as much stuff is I just
have my garages filled with bins full of
Legos
um and tons of things
um I found I was telling someone
upstairs if it's cool I found from 2000
I think it was 2012 like five or six
um Lego Hasbro exclusive Minifigs from
here and they had the little uh Sandy
Comic-Con uh logo I brought send them to
the stash bro and like within a like two
weeks they were gone one of them sold
for a thousand dollars a little
Spiderman minifig San Diego Comic-Con
exclusive and then I had a Batman zebra
Batman or something minifig in the
packaging five hundred dollars I'm not
Kenya was so excited but this is the
stuff being an actor you found your real
[__] profession selling me anything
in my Hasbro [__] and stuff
um it was just cool because again this
is stuff I like again we've come here so
many years I always collect the comic
Hasbro exclusives and other things
um and I I keep all of them I still have
all them they're in bins in my garage
but the Minifigs I'm not I love building
Legos but I'm not really into the
Minifigs so I was like I'm gonna send
them to the stash and see how to see if
they go and they win so it was pretty
awesome but again now we now we have to
um we love the house we love the
neighborhood the house
um we still are like we're getting
permits to and stuff to renovate we
gotta change some things in there
um we need another bathroom and stuff
like that but the the neighborhood's
great especially for the new kid because
the where we used to live by Kevin we
lived on these Hills right so like
trying to like walk Logan when she was
little do the hills was like up and down
and bumpy and [__] like that and people
run stop signs because they cut through
the neighborhood anyway we live in uh
and Silver Lake now and it's really nice
because like it's flat we take walks
it's beautiful we used to be the very
next year almost one block or two away
from each other and stuff which is kind
of mirrored where we lived in Jersey
growing up you didn't live too far from
me and whenever I would drive past
Jason's house out in Los Angeles like
which was near our house and the kid was
with me Harley would always be like oh
one day when I grew up I want to live
next to my best friend and I was like I
I don't live next to him he moved close
to us
but then when you moved there goes the
neighborhood man like everyone left you
right the parents left Harley left and
[__] everyone [__] bailed on you
you're like
no but you got to you you've been a lot
anyway at the in Jersey at the movie
theater which is awesome
um and it's fun I went there recently we
showed he showed well I mean he's been
doing a ton of stuff the wife won't let
me go as much since we've had the second
kid like I said we started getting on
this thing where Logan was at school a
lot and she had different of routine
um and so like I could fly Kevin like
hey I want Jay to come meet me for this
thing and I would come fly out and meet
him we did the different like the road
show and get old but now he's like hey
I'm doing this uh clerk script reading
uh can Jacob and my wife's like no
but I went and did the secret uh the Jay
and Song Bob Strikes Back we screened
the movie and then we did a q a
afterwards which was a lot of fun and
then you did the auction which is part
of it and it that was a lot of fun too
which I didn't expect so we got to you
know I tried to do my auction voice
which isn't very great but yeah
[Music]
yeah I tried to do the fast talk but
it's fun though it was fun owning a
movie theater is something that like
like every filmmaker I think dreams of
and stuff when I was a kid you know just
loved movies before I was a filmmaker
the idea of owning a movie theater was
like oh my God that would be amazing and
so our Hometown Theater was up for sale
so me and a couple of my friends from
back home
pulled some cash together and and bought
it and um it has been absolutely
it's been a blast coming up with fun
things to show and [__] but film
exhibition like is hurting after covet
it was seriously affected and stuff and
so getting people to come see new movies
that's modcastle that's the name of the
movie theater has been kind of like
difficult like [__] I talk about it back
there all the time opening night of
Avatar the Friday night that Avatar 2
opened up like the very first [__]
night
12 people showed up at our theater and
some people are like well you don't have
an iMac screen I was like yeah but
neither do does any theater near nearby
and stuff like that yeah
um Crete three did very well a lot of
places opening Friday night at our
theater we had [__] six people
um Shazam shes didn't at all [__]
it's just it's it's crazy but whenever
we do something like I've shown Mall
Rats with [__] uh Jason Lee and
Jeremy London we could sell the place
out Jason Lee came back we showed
Chasing Amy we sold the place out Jason
came we did Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back sold the place out Raquel Castro
who played the little Jersey girl in
Jersey girl now she's an adult she came
and we sold the [__] place out so all
of our stuff like Justin long is coming
August 12th and we're showing tusk
and that is sold out as well so it's
almost like and the other thing is like
when we show old movies people [__]
come like we showed the Blues Brothers
as part of a series called the movies
that made me and 150 people showed up
for the Blues Brothers 12 people came
for Avatar yeah 130 people came to see a
movie that they could easily like watch
at home or on their phone and then you
realize there's like a lot of nostalgia
built into it it's just not the same
anymore we live in an age of content
right where there's just like
everybody's making a show they're
resilience there's no longer like three
networks there's a zillion networks and
a bunch of streamers and we're just
constantly drowning in content and since
covet happened the audience has been
trained to be like well if I wait a
month I'm going to be able to watch it
at home and stuff so the movies just
don't seem to be like what they used to
be but when you show an old [__]
movie like a movie that [__]
grew up on oh my God man that that's
when they [__] come out we showed the
Muppet movie and had 160 people show up
at that point I turned to Ernie
O'Donnell runs the place I was like show
every Muppet Movie
they made a bunch of them at one point
like we'll be rich
um but it's been a lot of fun doing the
movie theater man like it's it's coming
up with programs and and being like oh
we're going to show [__] we're going to
show in September uh Dr Josh Rausch uh
who shoots our shows and whatnot you
know I'm from Hollywood Babylon he made
a movie called wrong reasons we're going
to be showing it there did you bring
free [__] to give away for your movie
where
yeah free [__] let's go [__] from
stickers and pins from Josh Rouse man uh
for wrong when does it come out
August 15th it comes out oh hey there
land lovers it's me Kevin Smith have you
ever wanted to get lost on high seas
with Jay and Silent Bob well you're
gonna have your chance in the year 2024.
join us with Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise
Askew live podcast every night we got a
movies on board there's a view Askew
Museum what else music dancing
hollering what are you waiting for man
Jameson bobcruisescue.com we will
protect you from sharks
um so being able to like do [__] with
your friends at the theater has been
very [__] rewarding but like if I was
in it for like the money that you make
off new movies not at all and you don't
even get to keep all the [__] money
no I bet yeah basically we keep like I
think it's 25 to 30 percent of a new
movie and you gotta pay for the
employees you got to pay for electric
and all that that's very secret and I
think I don't think it's much of a
secret I think everybody knows is that
the it's concessions that pays for
everything like I'm not in the movie
business I'm in the [__] popcorn
business yeah nice nice like and that's
why when you go to a movie theater it's
like why is this popcorn so expensive
it's because that's that's what pays the
[__] rent and keeps the lights on and
[__] like that so at our movie theater
we started doing auctions
um to like augment and [__] and so like
you know I've got tons of [__]
one-of-a-kind props and memorabilia and
[__] that's signed so before the movie
We tend to do these at any screening I'm
doing we tend to do these auctions and
the thing is like the auctions wind up
going for like an hour hour and a half
and [__] and there's some people that
have never been there before who are
like are we ever gonna watch a movie
so guess who's the auction's done so
it's been incredibly
um fun that aspect of it and stuff
um but yeah I wouldn't recommend [__]
buying a movie theater anybody it has an
apartment above it and that's where I
live when I'm in Jersey I used to go
stay at the Marriott Courtyard all the
time but now I could just go stay in the
apartment above the movie theater which
is kind of [__] adorable a Movie
Maker living in an apartment above a
movie theater is like a cobbler living
in a giant shoe you know there's just
something [__] sweet about it but I
hang out upstairs and the back stairwell
goes right into the back of the
concession stand so the nice thing about
living above a movie theater is anytime
you [__] want snacks yeah you just go
like you could be sitting there [__]
watching TV and you're like I want
Twizzlers and [__] you go downstairs
and they got Twizzlers and [__] so I'll
periodically go downstairs and just open
the door I'm wearing pajamas and a robe
and [__] and there's the people that
staff the place they're all [__] high
schoolers and so I'm always opening up
the door and terrifying a [__] high
school kid who's filling some popcorn
I'm like hey you know like what the [__]
don't mind me I'm just here for
Twizzlers and then [__] off and
disappear and [__] like that so I
[__] did this like right before I'm
there like almost every other week and
the last time I was there I was upstairs
and I was like
I feel like popcorn man you could smell
the popcorn upstairs I was like [__]
we make pretty good popcorn so I guess
I'm gonna get some popcorn [__] so I
went downstairs [__] opened the door
real quick fast and the person the kid
who was behind the concession stand they
didn't [__] they startled they were like
what the and I was like oh sorry man
sorry as I came to get some popcorn I
was like they they should have [__]
warned you about me
and she goes they did
and I was like what do you mean she's
gone they told me that periodically you
just [__] come out of the walls
and then disappear back into the bushes
like Homer and [__] like that
and I was like get out of here people
are talking about me she's like the
whole [__] staff talks about you
she's like we got a nickname for you I
was like what's that she goes we call
you The Phantom
pretty [__] fun though man owned in a
movie theater as much as it's not like
I'm never going to be able to retire off
it or something like that it's like
we've got it's not just a single screen
it's five [__] screens I own a
multiplex so at any given moment like
you could kick back watch whatever's
playing
most movies now we don't have film
projection we have digital projection
and digital projection is basically a
Blu-Ray so you can [__] pop in any
Blu-ray and sit there and watch [__]
movies downstairs man and so
we
recently had this thing where I was at a
one of the auctions I did at the the
spot Castle people were bidding against
each other for a [__] shirt or
something like that and one guy was just
like you know 100 bucks okay I was like
120 and the other guy was like 120 and
I'll give you a cut the Schumacher cut
of Batman Forever and I was like [__]
sold man
so I had a copy of I still do of Batman
Forever like the original cut that was
duped off of like the first like
generation Avid or something so it's
like it doesn't look pristine but it's
totally [__] watchable so I watched
it and [__] I was like this is [__]
fun and I started talking about it on
fat man beyond and people like [__]
show it show it and I was like well I
can't [__] show it I don't own it I
can't charge to show it but I can show
it for free and so we did uh recently we
did a
um a marathon of the clerks cartoon and
Brian and Jeff came uh who played Dante
and Randall that was also sold out and I
told people I was like look if you want
to stick around afterwards like I'll
I'll sh I'll just run the [__]
Schumacher cut because this is like my
living room so it's like coming over to
my house to watch a movie and [__] like
that and so the night started late it
was going to be minimum three hours
because the six episodes equals roughly
that and we were doing Q and A's after
after every other episode and stuff but
then it you know we did a big auction
that wound up going nearly two [__]
hours and then we did the program and
with the Q and A's it just by the time
and then afterwards we did photos like
[__] with people that bought like
pictures with us and [__] so by the time
the whole evening was over
it was 2 45 in the morning
so I was like there's going to be nobody
here to watch the [__] Schumacher cut
50 [__] people
toughed it out we're just like [__] you
I'm here for it and [__]
and so we [__] watched the Schumacher
cut until the [__] sun came up man it
was pretty wonderful so we did this
event like a long time ago I think it
was back in March where we did a thing
called clerks open all night where we
started the movie at midnight and we
showed clerks clerks two and clerks
three and then by the time it was over
it was like six in the morning and you
could sleep over you could wear pajamas
and [__] like that and some people were
just like really Charmed by the notion
of sleeping overnight in a movie theater
which is like ridiculous because our
seats are crazy [__] uncomfortable
and [__]
but uh it went so well that we're
[__] doing it again so at the end of
September we're doing open all night too
um and I think tickets go on sale like
next week or something like that but I
asked Jordan yeah Jason's wife I was
like you know we're doing open all night
too
you know essentially like can Jason come
out and play
can Jason come and be there for her and
she's like when is it and I was like
September like whatever it is the end of
September and she's like no he's not
allowed to go and I was like well
[__] I need him in January for sure
she's like what's in January and I was
like there's another program we're gonna
do she's like what is it I was like
we're gonna show we're going to show Jay
and Silent Bob Strike Back yeah Jay and
Silent Bob super groovy cartoon movie
and Jay and Silent Bob reboot so we're
going to show all three from midnight
till six in the morning and it's called
Jay and Silent Bob sexy sleepover
so she was like all right he can go to
that one nice
I'm gonna bring a [__] sleeping bag
everything it does it sounds appealing
to me that's like so I get why people
are like all right we can sleep in a
movie theater a [__] lay a sleeping
bag right bro you can sleep on the stage
that's what I mean some people stop
watching the movie and just be like look
at it oh [__] yeah I'll just sleep there
and I'll like do changes through the
night like I'll put on different pajamas
and [__] I'll put my hair up one way oh
it'll be awesome that's how famous
people sleep
and if they saw you sleep they would see
but I've seen for 30 years is you with
your hand down your [__] pants [__]
yeah that's ruling up a [__] story oh
yeah
I do always put my hand in my pants when
I see Matt wakes me Matt helps me get up
at conventions uh because I'm always
like man I'm gonna oversleep at the go
to the airport and he says every time
every time he's done it at least 10
times he said every time he comes in in
my hands in my [__] pants and [__]
it's because you're holding your dick
wishing in your sleep you're just like I
wish my boy's dick will be huge
no you really want to know why I think
so when I was younger I'm an older
brother there was a
weird stuff people got to go get old and
stuff you know I live with my mom was a
dope fiend blah blah blah but anyway I
live with my brother and my aunt from
like 12 to 16 or something like that 14
something
um anyway my brother lived in this house
my aunt raised him he was adopted my mom
was too young whatever but this
[__] I would fall asleep and
he'd bring his friends over Ed and
sometimes some other people I don't want
to say last names but he used to bring
like Ed over and so and so and all of a
sudden I'd get woken up because I'd have
a [__] morning piss boner right in my
tighty whities and this [__]
would flick my dick right and I'd wake
up and I'm like holy [__] you know and
they'd all be laughing at me and [__] so
I started sleeping with my pants on and
then if I [__] was like uncomfortable
I'd start putting my pants down to my
ankles so if I heard them come in I
could pull my pants up and check because
I was afraid he would flick my [__]
morning boner bro so maybe that's why I
think I cover it like yeah I'm
protecting it [__] he traumatized me
this [__] what is the [__] him
up now that I think about it what is the
logic though of wearing your pants
around your ankles and then pulling them
up if he comes in why not just wear them
because sometimes I would like fall I
didn't want to wear them because I'd be
uncomfortable hot and I'd be
uncomfortable and I'd want to see my
Underpants and [__] and feel the [__]
nice cold sheets on my ass and [__]
right but I'd be worried if it came in
I'd be able to pull my pants up and
[__] like hide or get up and run and
[__] so he didn't [__] [__] with me
but I think it's adorable that you like
I had to wear [__] pants because of
this guy
but I really think that might be why I
cover my my wien because I'm never
playing with it I don't like wake up and
I'm like half asleep and I'm playing
with it and [__]
all right sometimes it happens [__]
yeah you you
it's not that you wake up and play with
it you're awake and you play with it all
the time yeah well that that's true I
don't deny that I'm playing with it
right now while we're chatting bro
especially when I'm looking right in
your eyeballs
that wasn't even if that wouldn't
unnerve me if you were like yo I want to
[__] jerk off and stare in your eyes
I'd be like all right
what if it was like a mean look though I
was like
or would it be more pleasant if I was
like
I think I mean that's definitely I would
prefer that to you being like what the
[__] I'm so angry at you but I would if
you were like looking in my eyes I'd be
fine if you were like look into my dick
I'd be like who am I Elmer Fudd [__] no
like
yeah like that just to let you know if
that's something you're into all right
fair enough you heard it here guys so
lights
um all right sorry I got flashed in the
face but I like should I just give me a
disco light so I could be like
I thought you were saying lights to them
like Kill the Lights we're gonna do it
oh goodness
um all right kids I think we're just
about ready to get the show started
um
how many people have ever seen uh the
podcast Jay and Sam and Bob good old put
your hands together
how many people have never seen or heard
the podcast James zombie up good old put
your hands together
the guy right there is like what am I
paying for
it's a lot of talk of his dick
um this started years ago coming up on
[__] 13 years ago
um as an intervention podcast as he
mentioned very briefly before he used to
have like a big old issue with drugs and
stuff like that
um and so the idea was like let's do a
show every week where essentially you're
held accountable like where you talk
about because he used to keep it quiet
his [__] drug and alcohol problem and
stuff and I was like no you talk about
it loud and proud and [__] and then
there's more than
one sponsor so to speak anyone who
listens to the show could always check
in on you and be like how you [__]
holding up how you know you [__]
being good you being clean you're being
sober and stuff so that was the original
incarnation of the show and it it for
the first few years it worked incredibly
well
um it still works well today as you'll
hear in a couple seconds but what
happened was eventually the show wasn't
the reason for him to stay sober anymore
once he had Logan
suddenly having a kid like shaped him up
he didn't need a bunch of strangers to
be like are you being [__] sober and
[__] because he never wanted to let his
kid down which is kind of [__] sweet
but
[Applause]
um
but we honor like the origins The Secret
origins of the show uh by at a certain
point during any show uh getting to the
magic moment where we asked Jay how long
you been clean and sober man so it's
been 13 years
thank you and like three weeks yeah yeah
so August 2nd will be uh 13 years one
month so thank you thank you um we tend
to do the show in a bar all the time
yeah a show about sobriety surrounded by
a bunch of people who are like [__]
do it Jay
it started that way too I feel like even
the first well no not in the beginning
but it moved I think after about a year
we moved into a bar up at the universal
but anyway but yeah it was good luckily
I feel like it was never
that I liked alcohol but I don't feel
like it was the that wasn't the thing it
wasn't the sore tough one like we
weren't in like a Opium Den then it
would have been real tough
if anyone was like smoking heroin and
[__] I'm like yeah were you born in the
20s and [__] like that
no but I don't even know yeah and I
don't know if I've never been to one of
those spots I could picture I like
everyone just smoking Dove and [__]
using I guess I'd call it a [__]
Shooting Gallery I am so anyway but yeah
so 13 years one month do you can you
even uh
remember back to a time when when you
weren't sober like to me it's such a
[__] distant memory like I know we're
never supposed to say [__] never
right because in any one bad day it
could trip at all or whatever the [__]
but I it's become very hard to remember
many times when you were that person yes
you being
like just a super dad or something like
that it is it you know I uh I it's
it's crazy because it's been a while and
it's I just was thinking about this
other day because I feel like it's I
don't even get the same feelings I used
to get for the first five years like I
would pass something a location that I
like used the Burger King bathroom to
shoot up after I copped and I was dope
sick and every time I passed that for
years it's a commercial for Burger King
I've ever heard no but it's weird you
get like these weird like emotional
flashes and stuff and it happened for
years and years after but I don't even
it seems like less and less I'm getting
those and I and I don't remember like I
was thinking even Comic-Con I remember I
missed a couple years we've been coming
since we mentioned 95 but there's a few
years I missed and one year I didn't
miss but I remember I spent most of time
running around trying to get oxycontins
and they didn't out here it was a TR I
remember I ran around and I had like
didn't have a lot of money but I had
enough money to like take a cab to a
couple doctors and then I finally got a
doctor that Grady give it to me but he's
like what is this Oxycontin and he wrote
it on a script and I was like finally I
[__] got oxies and I was so sick by
this point I was like [__] and I was
sweating and I had to like meet you at
some point I'm like I'm running down I
have to meet him in an hour I gotta get
this and the guy writes me a script and
I go to the pharmacy and they're like we
can't fill this and I'm like why and
like this is oxycontin you have to have
it on a triplicate and I'm like what the
[__] a triplicate right and and I had
no idea because in Jersey it didn't have
to be on a triplicate but when I moved
when I came here they did anyway so I
had to go find the doctor he had just
went to his rotation at a hospital I
[__] cabbed it to the right thing and
I was like sorry doc they said they want
to build it and he's like oh it's on a
triplicate I got to think about this and
he wounded up giving it to me still but
he was hesitant but anyway like what a
[__] nightmare that was my Comic-Con
weekend it was like filled with that and
I mean we did some panels and some
signings I think
um but yeah so every once in a while
someone will come up and be like dude I
Met You in back in you know 2000 Titanic
Comic-Con and [__] will show me a
picture and you could see I'm like
sweating and chilling you're like do you
have a [__] triplicate
I'm like you just throwing the flashback
to me
um but anyway I'm glad that I don't have
a Doctor Who's like I want I'm going to
the hospital do my shift and save lives
and you're like yo can I get two more of
those things yeah no I'm sure he was
blown it was weird I mean he was I think
he knew at that point but he was like
already gave it to him and he already
paid me for the appointment
um and he just felt bad I guess but at
this I'm shocked he wasn't like [__] you
you little junkie jerk off get out of
here you know I mean but uh but yeah it
was a nightmare so thank goodness that
hasn't happened and I again knows type
of situations I don't even remember him
as much so that's good bless you
so yeah so thank goodness man we are
here and two babies and and Comic-Con
silver man [__] drinking red bulls
drinking the Bulls in the liquid death
um if we love them we do uh in February
of this coming year of 2024
um as you see I'm only reminded because
it's literally all I'm excited is uh
we're taking our first cruise together
um Jay and Silent Bob's uh Cruz Askew
how many people are going on the cruise
[__] yes [__] yes we'll see you there oh
look at that face right there holy
remember that face uh 3 000 of us
crammed on a boat together uh with all
the common interests of like you in the
movies and stuff oh [__]
I'm very excited about this sincerely
let's do the right face oh sorry
oh no three hour tour
my little man right here all jerk one of
his off and I don't know you look like
Tom Tom Cruise and Vanilla Sky man [__]
yeah thanks all right a mask of yourself
over your face
um are you looking forward to being I
have high seas I I mean I am because
I've never been on a cruise uh and just
the concept of like being on a boat with
a bunch of people that we're gonna watch
like there's gonna be comedy there's
gonna be music gambling
um some [__] video gaming and stuff
it does sound like a fun time to me so
I'm excited about it to see the whole
thing and just uh because we're going to
the Bahamas we get off right I've never
been to the Bahamas that'll be fun
um and I'm Gonna Be by I think I don't
know if my wife's gone so I think I'm
gonna be in my room and [__] on top like
I'm excited about it I'm excited I'm
gonna be talking like oh
on top of the mountain I'll cover it in
cheese I lost my poor meatball now
um because I like the idea of like I
don't have to share the bed and I can no
no no I'm just saying like
I sorry because the room I was nervous
about being in the boat like in the deck
because I would get claustrophobic and
that my wife showed me she's like oh no
your room's like up higher and you have
a balcony and stuff so you won't feel
claustrophobic and I'm just saying like
I just I just think it'll be fun like
they should there's like a pool and
there's all sorts of fun things and I
think it'll be nice man I'm gonna give
Dutch Rudders and [__] it's gonna be
[__] fantastic do you ever spend much
time on a boat I've never been on a boat
I mean a sailboat I've been on little
boats I've been deep sea fishing and
[__] wait you think we're going on a
sailboat no no we're going on a big big
boat yeah yeah I've never been on a
cruise ship okay yeah are you scared no
oh you're asking me as if you're like
have you ever been on one
we were talking about boats and you were
like I ain't been on a sailboat I'm like
no no I've never done a sailboat
[__] no no I've never been on a
big cruise ship I never even stepped on
one and [__] so I'm just I think it
could you refuse to watch The Love Boat
when you were a kid oh hell yeah that's
exactly the bones
depression and sinuses with talk what
was the name doc [__] just duck yeah
okay
but I'm excited Come Aboard Muse is
expecting you
I love how you remember like nine words
yeah
and then the rest is
I wanna we're getting flashed why I I
think
oh is that right we got to move on yeah
oh [__]
um
[__] you don't have to go home but you
got yeah I think we got photos and some
people are away um but yeah man I think
we should auction one thing off there's
another [__] show after after this
right like didn't I that play this place
at a certain point turns into movies
after dark and they have Music Live
music's here a band and stuff
they're doing live karaoke tonight oh
[__]
would you stick around to do a karaoke
song yeah you could do love bug you're
like yeah yeah yeah
um we got uh two three more days of
Comic-Con kids uh
it's going to be a good [__] time
Comic-Con this year since there are no
[__] actors and stuff since a lot of
Hollywood's not here it's kind of
returned to its roots of just fandom of
just people who all come together
because they like a thing shared
interests and stuff like that so
hopefully you all enjoy yourselves at
Comic-Con uh this summer kids it's a
weird one but doesn't mean it's a bad
one but I stretch the imagination allows
us to actually get back to what started
this whole thing the Kami part of
Comic-Con my comic books and stuff like
that I get made fun of a lot online
people like say Comic-Con I'm like
Comic-Con
that's where I feel like you sometimes
mispronouncing a [__] thing but I
feel like it's been called that I mean
I've been calling it since like from the
beginning it's Comic-Con fair enough and
I never say like someone's like you
going to sdcc I'm like what the [__] is
that and they're like you know there's
too many letters I just think of even
calling it Comic-Con and but you're
right because then if we're like hey
you're going to that comic book
convention in Tennessee like for some
reason this this has always been
Comic-Con to me so but to a lot of
people they're like oh we're going to
Comic-Con they're like [__] the Russians
and it's like
that's nothing to [__] do with that
uh so kids I hope uh you all have a
wonderful Comic-Con as we say back in
Jersey do you have a good time this
evening
[Applause]
I can't thank enough uh thank you enough
for coming out you sold out this show so
[__] fast man we didn't even really
get to offer tickets to the general
public so thank you for joining us on
this very first night of Comic-Con uh
but we have no show whatsoever no Jay
and Silent Bob get old without the only
one of us whose real name is in the
title of this [__]
uh give it up for the one the only the
American Icon Jason news kids thank you
thank you thank you and that is Jane
sound Bob good old for this week I'm
Kevin Smith Jesus
[Music]
thank you
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
foreign